Woohoo!
Hello everybody!
Welcome, welcome, welcome Welcome in!
Welcome,
welcome Lovely weather we're having.
Isn't it?
Uh That's...
That's...
It's chilly, a little chilly out.
Hi, hi, hi.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
We're here.
Thank you for the voice back, Vidal.
Feeling kind of Silent Hill in here.
Oh, I can't believe, I can't believe Silent Hill.
And finally, I fell right into the scenery.
I know, I know.
Thank you for the voice back.
Thank you.
I'm so excited.
I've been so excited for this game ever since it was announced.
So I'm like, I saw so many people already beating it.
I guess it's not too long, it seems.
I expected, I don't know.
I feel like JRPG.
Do you count this as JRPG?
It's not quite, but you know what I mean.
Like, it's, I always expect them to be so much longer.
I feel like other Silent Hills were longer.
No.
You can, okay, but it's like, it's a Japanese game that's an RPG.
Kind of.
Okay.
But like, okay, in my brain, I'm like, okay, I can't explain it.
You guys just have to be on the same page as me.
Okay, just understand.
Silent Hill 3 is like four to six hours?
Okay, well.
The original Silent Hill is like six hours?
Okay, I played them when I was like a little baby.
And I took a long time, I guess.
In between homework.
I was sure they're short.
Okay, well, okay.
Back it up.
Back it up, back it up, back it up, everybody.
Back it up, okay, hold on.
Back it up, back it up.
We're gonna start at the beginning.
We're starting at the beginning.
we're starting at the beginning i have not played a silent hill game since three
um so it's been a long time even though i really like silent hill as a series it's been a long long time since i played anything i never played four i played one two three i never played four I never play, I really, you know what I've been thinking about recently is I have been wanting to play Shattered Memories,
the Wii game.
Oh, never played PT.
That's different.
That was not Silent Hills yet.
That was PT.
And honestly, I didn't play the 2 remake because I don't know.
I was just like, oh, well, I already played 2.
Why do I need to play it again?
I don't I don't know actually
I mean like I played Delta which was just three again I guess it's like I okay I'll be honest 100% I wanted to wait until what people said about it because I was really scared about Bloober Team I was scared that Bloober Team had it And I was like, oh,
it's not going to be very good.
So, and then, and then all the good reviews came out and everyone was saying it was so good.
And then by the time I was like, oh my gosh, yeah.
The hype had died.
And I was like, well, I'll get around to it eventually.
But, so, I remember being so like, when I saw that they were working on two.
But they apparently did a very good job.
with it um this game i'm very excited for because um it just i don't know anything about it besides the trailers i've avoided anything of people playing it and everything so
hi i keep mixing up bloober team in the chinese room for some reason who i don't know the other one good luck finding a new cafe to haunt huh what huh first playthrough of f is roughly 10 to 12 hours yeah that's what i i googled how long to beat however to get the full story it requires multiple runs as new game plus changes things what what this is gonna be wait that's so crazy thanks so much for the voice back mito do you have heard it she just said mito so cute yay
new cafe in Silent Hill.
I'm moving to Silent Hill Silent Hill F so that I can have a cute girlfriend and a Seifuku.
I will be taking notes on your playthrough then.
Okay.
I'll do my best.
But yeah.
Why did I always think that Silent Hill games were so long?
I guess because when I played them before I would have to play a little bit and then I would get scared and then I play a little bit and then I have homework and I play a little bit and then I get scared and rinse and repeat
yes that's probably it but anyway um so good it felt long maybe maybe maybe but so this is my first time playing like a new silent hill wow wow I I really do want to play Shattered Memories, though.
Because doesn't that also have, like, a sanity thing?
Also, please stop spamming!
Thank you!
If you spam, it's going to be less likely for me to play a game.
Silent Hill Phantom!
Yeah!
Okay.
Fear makes people play slower.
That's true.
But I'm brave.
Maybe.
Oh, I got some of the bonuses.
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, I didn't get the... I thought... wait.
I thought you only got this if you did the...
Um...
The, what's it called?
The...
Deluxe edition.
It's a pre-order bonus.
I don't even know if I pre-ordered it.
See the tattoo?
I...
I didn't!
I was looking!
I didn't see it though.
Early window bonus.
Complementary copy?
Who do you think I am?
You think I would get a complimentary copy?
Heck no.
Oh, strange.
That's so bizarre.
Supogaki finds...
Thank you.
I hit Petty.
First time Super Chatter, today's my birthday!
Happy birthday!
Oh, sure, thank you so much for the 50 gifted, holy moly.
Holy, thank you so much.
Okay, let's just get into it then.
Oh, what's this?
Yeah, well, the story, of course.
Puzzles.
Why is it default to hard?
Lost in the fog.
Wait, balanced puzzle experience?
Are they really bad?
The puzzles?
Bunny outfit is deluxe.
I got that one, the pink bunny outfit.
Did I buy the deluxe on accident?
Thank you so much.
You guys are sending so many super chats today.
What the heck is happening?
Oh, thank you.
What's happening?
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to my email.
What did I buy?
Okay, I did pre-order it though, because or I wishlisted it, but Oh, I did I think I was like It's just 10 more bucks for a For the bunny outfit
Oopsie I forgot I forgot My bad, sorry I'm confused at my own Purchase
Um, anyway, puzzles, are they difficult?
Anybody who knows?
You know what, let's just go- we're gamers, we're gamers.
Pure white.
Innocent white.
Designated school uniform.
Oh!
Ah!
Thank you so much, organizer, for the five you did.
Thank you, thank you for the voice back.
Thank you!
Oh, wait.
It's so cute!
It's actually so cute!
Why the rabbit ears?
Is it based off of the bunny from...
Three?
The pink bunny...
I can't remember its name if it had one.
Is it based off of him?
I mean, he did pay for it.
Yeah, but I feel like if I'm doing...
My first playthrough, I like to always stay...
You know, do tradition.
It's a Labua girl!
But this is so cute.
It's so cute.
Robbie the Rabbit, was that his name?
Maybe we do the first playthrough and then if I want to get the true end.
It's pretty easy to switch.
It does say like you can switch.
So we'll start with this and then we can switch later if we feel like it.
Whatever.
It's cute but immersion breaking.
It'll make me less scared.
A little baby!
I forgot to say, I- I forgot to say, I- I made the voice as Japanese, is that okay?
Hinako?
Oh, Oh, the boy Oh, ma'amago to be able to A-g-a-g-n-g-a-g-g-a-g-g-a-goto
Let's go, Oh-mago-tosio-k-k-eo-k-k-o-k-k-o-k-koto
I'm also really bad with names, so I included the names.
I thought that was a nice feature.
She's a ton, thank you for that.
Thank you.
She's so cute.
Oh,
why did my controller vibrate?
Cute.
Aww.
It
might get spooky.
Did you see the person that refunded it because their review was scary?
They're blinding!
Who does the music in this game?
Opening sequence.
Me.
It was me.
Oh, is it Kira Yamaoka again?
Okay, good.
I'm in.
this wow you guys are all so talented we have a great team in the chat today
she's even sitting on to the side in the photo so sam
We're not seeing like anybody's faces.
It's kind of interesting.
Hinako?
Oh!
Head down the mountain.
Oh.
Look at our place.
Wow.
Uniform is so cute.
Oh, I like how we just...
We don't turn around.
We just walk backwards.
Frame?
Is it dropping for you guys?
I might want to lower the resolution.
Oh, I see it now.
I'm comparing the OBS.
Oh, it's not for me!
It's only on OBS!
That's so weird.
Wait, what?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
One moment, please.
Oh, interesting, interesting.
Why?
Hmm.
I have the frame rate limited.
I...
Like, I guess I could turn the resolution down a little bit, but I don't want to.
Because then it'll be too small for me to see.
Why is it a Panini projection?
Let's see.
I'm just walking and judging, walking and looking, and walking and looking.
What just happened?
My game is haunted, you guys!
I didn't do that!
My... that was my controller disconnecting.
That's never happened before.
What's going on?
in 2025 is wild.
Okay, look, I have to say this literally every time I play a new game, a AAA title.
You can never judge a game's performance when a VTuber is playing it.
And I mentioned VTuber specifically because VTubers have also like 500 other programs that we are running at the same exact time.
So, yeah, I have to play at a lower frame rate for your sake because i am an anime woman okay thank you thank you very much
okay we're going down the mountain is there anything oh what's my journal me me there's not a single extraordinary thing about me except maybe for being tall for a girl my age i used to be in track and field club which is probably why i'm I'm better at sports than most girls.
I guess I got used to running around a lot when I was a kid since I preferred playing with the boys.
I will admit I can be quite stubborn at times.
I don't like accepting things that other people decide for me, even if it's the right thing to do.
More than once I've rebelled and made the wrong decision, only to regret it later.
Mom.
She means to me it.
My mother.
If I had to choose one word to describe her, it would be...
pitiful she's the one who bears the brunt of my father's violent moods and malicious abuse when i was younger she used to protect me from him so i didn't hate her back then but maybe i do hate her now even as my father screams in her face throws bulls at hers and sends her out for alcohol late at night she remains ever loyal to him i just cannot will not accept her way of life papa well maybe not papa is a good way to quote mean though the people could only see six
yeah yeah he's a kanta my father when I first learned of the term patriarchal husband and that it meant a man who does nothing but boss his wife around he was the first person to come to mind dad barely talks he ignores me when I tell him good morning but if I say nothing he gets angry angry he just explodes he loses all control over his emotions in the blink of an eye he yells at mom throwing things around and even hits us why can't you act like that in public why does everyone else get only get to see his quiet calm side if it meant that i wouldn't have to spend another second with him in that house i'd happily let myself be taken away she's asking oh oh brother
Kinuta Junko, my older sister.
She's one of the prettiest and kindest people I know, and there's nothing she can't do.
I can rely on her for anything.
Honestly, she's the greatest sister anyone could ask for.
She's always been there for me.
Ever since the day I was born, until...
Until she left to get married.
Oh, my God.
She became Ria-Ju and left us behind.
Is there anything that...
I guess we just go down the mountain, huh?
That's what it said to do.
Hmm.
I didn't see like anything to pick up or um what's this way
it's funny too I say that about the oh wait this seems down the mountain hold on let's go the other way first um I've been having like some monitor issues today with like flickering so hopefully my monitor isn't gonna give up
pretty path
Let's run.
I don't know why I'm walking.
I'm taking in the atmosphere.
Okay, someone's home.
Hello?
Knock, knock.
They say it shows cakes than horror.
Hello?
Anybody home?
Hello, I hear you in there!
It's me and Minto.
I'm ready.
Oh, and that we cannot go.
Can't see.
Oh, how do I read this?
Oh, A.
Entry to mountain prohibited.
Oh.
I see.
A landslide.
This place is pretty big.
I know places like this.
Art can be pretty big.
You know, it's countryside kind of stuff.
yeah hello you got chickens in there a cat it is countryside japan absolutely this is so pretty though pick up local doctors know there have been sightings of foxes coming into town recently i'm sure that the older generations who have grown up learning to respect foxes are fine but I'm concerned for the children who may try and chase or provoke the creatures.
Foxes by nature are not aggressive.
But just like wild dogs, they carry diseases such as rabies.
Tet, tet, tet, tet, sorry.
Tetness.
An equinochosis.
To name a few.
The town committees should send out warnings to ensure people don't get unnecessarily close to them.
I was like, I thought Japan is like one of the countries that, But, okay, you can correct me if I'm wrong.
And I'm not trying to be like, Japan is so awesome.
But I thought Japan, like, doesn't have rabies.
Or rather, they're very, like, what's the word?
Extreme about it.
Oh, the 60s!
You're right.
Oh, I thought this was a staircase.
It's in the 60s.
But nowadays, I think that every country has it.
But, like, no, they, they, like, are extremely, like, what's the word, proactive about rabies.
I don't think, if they have rabies, it's, like, extremely, extremely rare, is what I've heard.
You can correct me.
They done killed it pretty well, yeah?
doesn't have rabies or really another place that doesn't have it i guess when you're like so insulated like that it's much easier to control it unless you know unless it like gets out of total control but oh i'm just gonna walk in your plants okay i'm smushing your garden so sorry
silent hill the works of yuki she's seven and mint phantom are all subjects that take a lot of space in my brain.
Yeah!
Also, if I miss something, you can be like...
Try not to backseat too much, but if I miss something, you can...
Of course, let me know.
Be like, hey, you miss something.
Oh, this is where I can change my outfit.
Oh, come on.
What should I do?
Oh, and here's tutorials.
Oh, exploration.
You can see a list of things you can do.
You can save your progress by going to record.
Let's just save.
We're already here.
Change costume.
Oh, wow.
You really can just change it so easily.
Okay, nice.
Good to know.
Australia has its own litany of wildlife issues that make rabies look like a joke.
I mean, the spiders.
That's just...
Drinking at this time of day.
That could be old.
Wait, what is this?
A woman is only complete when she's loved.
Featuring the latest fashion for young women so pure they make even...
They even make flowers blush.
Wow.
Seishun Shoujo, okay.
Oh, there's so much going on around here.
We can, like, explore the whole village.
The whole mountainside.
Well, it's a good thing I'm loved by so many!
I'm so beloved by so many people!
Oh.
Oh, I think they need to re-wash these.
They're stiff.
This game is so pretty.
And I don't even have it at the highest textures.
Oh.
Why?
Is she always out of breath, girl?
I thought you were good at sports.
You got that asthma?
You okay?
Is it the altitude?
She's always breathing.
You get loved, nerd.
Wait, I wanna...
Before we go this way, I wanna go to the other side first.
I am loved.
She's stressed.
Okay, that's fair.
Okay.
Whose house is it?
Oh, fancy.
Knock, knock.
Are you looking for another daughter?
Do you have a daughter?
Do you want a daughter?
Okay.
VTuber level stamina.
Hey, hey, hey.
What's this?
Water.
Okay.
Uniform is so cute.
Hold on, I just want to appreciate it for a second.
Look how cute she is.
So it's so traditional.
Like, but the little details on it make it so good.
It's so good.
I love me just a standard Seifoku.
Didn't know about the writing director for this game?
Ryuki, she's seven?
Oh my gosh, yes!
That's...
Oh, it's starting to get really foggy, huh?
Uh-oh.
Ebisuga Oka.
I live in the small rural town of Ebisuga Oka.
Before the war, the town was lively due to an influx of people coming for the coal mines and dam construction going on in the northern mountains.
After the dam construction finished and the coal mine closed down, it just became a sad little town.
The grand iron bridge that connects the town to the nearby city is the only reminder of this town's sorry town the sorry town's former glory okay we're going to the general store it's getting awfully foggy uh-oh anybody here knock knock where are you people
the coal mines they yearn for the mines they yearn cute Oh,
well.
Well, well, well.
Oh, my gosh.
There it is.
The silent hill.
Nice parking, bozo.
How's anyone supposed to get through there?
This has got to be something I can read.
No?
Oh, yes.
There's no driver.
Hi!
Oh!
Trail.
Ew!
Oh, sick.
I hope I don't get nightmares from this game.
Wait, is that his?
What is that?
That don't look so...
How did this guy even drive into this situation?
Hmm.
Yeah, it looks fresh.
Wipe your shoe, wipe your shoe.
Alright.
I wonder how they...
In this game will...
Okay.
I wonder how they'll alert you of enemies nearby.
In this one.
Ooh, it's starting to get real spooky, scary!
Oh, this is the shortcut?
Uh...
Big red arrows, hopefully.
Oh.
Australian spiders aren't as bad as the slightly, oh, the highly venomous jellyfish.
Oh, that sound great too.
This is me listening to your...
Listening to your rumors?
Don't worry about it.
It's just me.
I've got nobody to tell.
Don't worry about it.
I can't crawl through every crawl space.
Okay, that's fine.
I thought that was bread.
I was gonna get excited.
I don't mind the gossip.
I'm not gonna spread it around town or anything.
I'm gonna Isekai truck and get Isekai himself.
That sounds like its own plot.
What?
Sakuko.
Where are you going?
Oh,
I should keep going or that.
Are we friends?
Why should she keep calling me that?
That's suspicious.
Wait, maybe our Dirtle.
Sakuko.
One of my friends.
Oh wait, the art is so cute!
She's always got her head in the clouds and is a little strange.
She's constantly trying to worm her way out of paying me back for the 500 yen I lent her that one time.
Hey!
Her father is the head priest of Sennen-Sugi Shrine in town.
in town.
She seems to take great pride in donning the traditional Miko robes and selling charms during the New Year celebration.
How much would 500 yen be?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, we're dropping frames.
How much would 500 yen be nowadays?
Or back then.
No, back then.
It's the 60s.
Maybe, like, $10?
Maybe?
3K.
I don't know about that.
Name, Suzutani, Miami.
Last scene wearing white blouse, long navy skirt, beige neckerchief with black polka dots.
Details on the disappearance.
The rest has been torn off.
500 yen in 1960 is $3,000 today!
Actually!
3,000 yen today!
That's crazy!
Wow!
What the?
That's so crazy!
Look at this rock!
What is it?
What's it doing there?
Hmm.
Hello, welcome back!
Thank you!
Oh, is this the shrine?
Well, what's down here first?
Construction.
I got guy.
How did I get get?
How?
Does she speak?
Okay, still under construction.
When are they going to be finished?
I don't know.
What is it?
It looks like a grave.
It doesn't look like construction.
It's kind of spooky, no?
No?
It's kind of spooky.
You got one guide.
What did I get one guide?
There were so many people!
What about the prize?
There were so many people saying it though.
There were so many people saying...
I wonder what's the first creepy crawly we're gonna encounter.
There's a man!
That!
It's this guy!
It's the first creepy crawly!
Yuai Yu Shu.
Shu's been my best friend since forever.
He's my partner.
We've been having play dates for as long as I can remember.
When we played make-beliefs space wars, we'd call each other partner.
And for some reason, it just kind of stuck.
Kids of the Shoah era tend to look down on the other sex, but never Shu.
When I rebelled against my parents because they told me to act like a girl, he was the one who understood my feelings the most and stood by me.
a tom tom boy it's like me when i was a baby wisp i'm trying to enter everybody's home sorry eyeball
what you got there eyeball um
So awkward.
I thought you guys were besties.
What are these?
Candy?
I don't think there's cigarettes, are they?
Oh.
Shiu-kun, you're on the way.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like to talk to somebody.
I was like, yeah.
I was like, I was like, that.
That's why I was like, oh yeah.
Oh, my goodness.
If I knew I'd have to get it, I'd have to come back.
Yeah, I'll just keep it.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I'll be back to the point where I'm coming What?
The 500 yen?
Oh, we're smoking.
What the?
Who the fuck comes?
Hinako?
Come here.
Oh?
What?
Oh, okay.
Escape the fog monster.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
We're running, we're running, we're running.
Oh, my God.
We're not running fast enough.
I thought you were gonna track.
What happened?
This way.
You're right.
Oh, God.
Did I choose the wrong way?
Oh, eight.
Oh, my God.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
That's right.
Uh, oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
I tried to, I might have just screwed myself.
Just kidding.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
I'm so...
Oh, ah, ah.
Ah!
We're running, we're running.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah!
What's happening?
Silent Hill!
The laughing is so creepy.
Oh my god.
Be careful!
Surely it doesn't know how to climb.
We're smarter.
We're human.
Oh no.
Okay.
What did we get?
Oh, note from Shu.
Hey, partner.
These painkillers should work best for you.
They'll not only take care of your headaches, but also any pain from injuries.
I suspect that the main cause behind your nasty headaches is from you unconsciously grinding your teeth when you're upset.
Does that sound about right?
Oops.
I-bo-zoned.
I'm bo-zoned.
talk or anything just call my name and i'll be there oh so it wasn't smokes you guys were wrong too it wasn't smokes and it wasn't candy well this could be candy red capsules painkillers in red capsules or in capsules relieves pain and raises spirits we have sanity wait so how do i use it equipment items items take wait how do i take it Ah,
okay.
It was literally telling me.
I went straight for the journal.
Is there anything here?
Nothing that anyone offered that we can steal for our own benefit?
Disappointing?
Okay.
I thought he was gonna give a note like, Hey, meet me at this place later.
I feel like this game is probably pretty linear.
But I could be wrong.
Oh, bandage.
Greatly restore itself.
Yeah, I don't think we're gonna get our money back.
I don't know if we're gonna get our money.
Wait, we don't even know where we are?
Okay.
Sakako didn't seem very in good shape, I'm just saying.
You can explore a bit.
Oh, really?
Find a way back to Chizuruya General Store.
Okay.
Oh, we could go up.
What's over here?
What's this?
Oh, more... more drugs.
They're not drugs.
She's a good girl.
She doesn't do bad drugs or smoke like you guys assumed.
But I don't recommend.
Oh, sorry.
Taking drugs that you find in the alleyway.
Oh, wow.
Me.
Two seconds ago.
Wow, this game seems pretty linear, maybe.
Or I guess, who knows?
It's fine if you live.
live here.
Is it?
Did I miss something?
Was somebody there?
Did I miss it?
Shoe?
What kind of shoe do you think is a running shoe?
Uh-oh.
I don't like these at all.
Oh gosh, I think so.
Oh, I don't like going through these.
little wait these little shortcuts out oh i don't like it he's a nike
that atmosphere is good why is all right i guess to keep out maybe like raccoons and stuff
oh gosh it's scary oh the game just saved that's never a good time when the game i don't saves for just whatever reason it feels like it okay whoa i don't think we're in kansas anymore
i don't have a weapon we
could oh she does though oh we're so
oh my god oh it's so awesome How do you know I'm there?
Oh, so good.
Oh, so spooky!
B to evade attacks.
If you dodge just before an enemy's attack lands, you will perform a perfect dodge and recover your stamina.
Oh, they're like, hey, make sure you read this, dummy.
We're not letting you just click through the game.
Was that a perfect dodge?
Oh my god.
Is there a weapon?
Sorry.
That sounds so scary.
Is she still coming?
How do I
know if it's a perfect dodge or not though?
Trying to figure out.
I'm trying to test it.
Time slows down.
Oh my god!
So good!
Ah!
Dang it!
Oh no no.
If I die it's okay.
I want to get this kind of right.
I'm practicing you guys!
Oh!
Not...
Not good timing maybe.
Oh my god!
No?
I need to get the timing.
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
Okay, oh, whoops.
It's a D-pad.
Oh, no.
I thought it was...
Oh.
Oh, LB and then D-pad.
That's right.
I'm gonna go.
Oh!
Is this a dead end?
Oh, I think I screwed myself.
Oh, wait.
No, it's not.
Just kidding.
Um, hmm.
This way.
Oh, my God.
The sound effects are so...
Wait, what's in there?
Oh, hey.
Um, don't come after me, please.
I didn't get to- I didn't check that thing.
Let's just let her do her thing over there.
We're just gonna come up here.
She gone?
I don't see her.
Maybe she's-
Maybe she's gone!
Scary.
So...
Stinking spooky.
Where'd she go though?
Huh.
Mysterious.
Would love like...
a pipe or something.
Oh, it's just more like that.
You know what?
That's good though.
We'll take that.
We take those.
Maybe she ran back up here.
I don't...
Not particularly want to go see it.
Don't particularly want to check.
I think we'll keep going.
Hmm.
Where...
And then there's a map.
Oh, oh.
Where are we?
We're trying to get to there.
Oh, we're like going the opposite direction.
Oh, but I think...
Oh, I do need to go back.
Yeah, because I think...
Wait.
What?
We just came from...
Up there.
But I guess it is a dead end.
Because it shows it not...
We came from...
So I guess it is a dead end.
So we're kind of going the right way, perhaps.
Maybe.
Map is crazy.
Is there a run button there is?
I'm playing it safe for now.
It's a little spooky.
Uh-oh, someone didn't finish their laundry.
More?
Let's go?
I'm playing it safe.
Oh, I...
Oh, my God.
It's so scary.
Why is it so loud?
Oh, gosh.
Why did it save again?
Just got my voice back!
Thank you!
Oh, in here.
Oh, well, oh, I pressed B.
Sorry, instinctively.
Instinctively?
No!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
Japanese homes are so scary sometimes.
Can't open.
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh, why are these so scary?
Yokan.
A jelly-like dessert filled with red bean paste.
A bite-sized delight.
That doesn't look very appetizing right now, though.
Offering certain items that will allow you to receive faith.
Interesting.
combo we have nothing really so far except dodging wait what did it say if you run out of stamina you will be out of breath and won't be able to act until recovered okay and fleeing yeah that's what these games are about baby just running for it what else did i miss here the map Oh wait.
You can check your current objective by using Y.
Okay, cool.
Collectibles.
Checking objects.
The drawings are so cute.
Oh.
What is that thing?
It's like a little worm.
Nope.
Maybe it's a face.
Oh.
Hmm.
Um...
Uh...
Oh, what is a face?
Bloody key.
A key with unknown blood...
Unknown bloodstays, not sure what it unlocks.
Uh...
Okay.
Cool.
Guys, some more meds.
Nice.
We take those.
How did this get in here?
I thought it was gonna have me like jump out the window like...
But I guess not.
Leave!
The key doesn't fit!
Oh my god, we're so screwed.
Wait, we're so screwed.
Is it gonna be here?
Somewhere in here?
Oh my gosh.
I used the bloody key!
Jump?
Jump.
Get off the...
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, but...
Oh my gosh!
Get the heck out of me!
Oh my...
I've returned while avoiding monsters.
Okay!
Yeah.
Yeah, mazui.
Oh my gosh.
You're so scary.
I should have played this with a heart rate monitor.
Okay, where are we anyway?
Okay, that's what I thought that we needed to go around.
And we'll try...
Maybe...
Those look like dead ends.
and around and circle through there into the foggy zone.
So scary!
I figured there was gonna be a monster in there.
I wish I could have explored a little bit more, but I was...
I should have explored the downstairs area first.
Oh well.
How would a heart rate monitor work on a ghost?
Well, my ectoplasm would just go...
Like a jelly.
I think I need to go that way.
Move?
Just run?
This way?
Okay, now I'm lost.
Hold on.
I'm going the wrong way.
Oh!
Okay, if I turn around...
There might be an item in the dead end.
Yeah, but I don't want to run into this guy.
Or I don't want to be around this guy in the dead end!
Maybe she'll leave.
Did she leave?
Am I safe?
No.
I think I've crossed that bridge.
I go past that bridge.
Okay.
Wait.
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
The bridge is where I came from.
Okay, never mind.
I'm going the right way.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, you see her over there?
Okay.
Quietly now, without being noticed.
A cult?
A small hairbrush specifically meant to be used in religious ceremonies.
Interesting.
Yields a great deal of faith.
Let's pray.
Use faith to fully restore your sanity if you have chosen story as your action...
difficulty level then you can recover both your health and sanity by without using faith oh have use faith you have received the hokora to obtain omamori okay at least you have this nice soothing soundtrack yeah i feel so good right now i feel so so good right now all for items wait what do what do Omamori do besides like protection like Omamori is like a protective thing but what does it do in this case well we have this comb I've received 300 wait is this gotcha
am I doing Silent Hill gotcha right now okay it's 300 okay let's do our first
stamina.
Yippee!
Okay.
Does it just... Oh my gosh, and it goes up every time.
Oh, I got my... I forgot about my bonuses.
Fried tofu.
Let's go.
Aburage.
Nice.
Divine water.
First aid kit.
I got these for spending more money.
But the gotcha is free.
It's fine.
It's like in-game gotcha.
I don't mind that kind of stuff.
Let me save one more time since I just got the stuff.
Okay.
Um.
She's wailing.
Does it automatically equip?
Oh.
Equipment.
Sorry.
I was so scared.
I just clicked it immediately.
But not in combat use the lines and go to equipment and to select the Omamari.
Okay.
Here.
Equipment.
Ah!
Here we go.
Omamari.
Oh wait, wait, I got two.
Slightly restores health upon picking up food items.
I think max stamina right now is better.
Gotcha.
In a horror game, call it wailing.
Like, ah, wailing!
The audio is pretty good.
You can hear her stalking you.
Wait, is it kind of low for you guys?
I can hear her stalking me right behind me.
Yes, I can hear her stalking me perfectly.
It's very scary.
I don't like it.
Oh, wait.
I just realized I had my headphones up a little bit.
There's a lot of health items in game, but nothing to recover stamina.
So stamina is the most important.
Ah.
Seems good?
Okay, thank you.
Oh.
I don't want to look behind me, but...
Scary game is scary.
That looks... I don't like that.
Okay.
Where are we now?
Okay, so...
Well, okay.
We're just gonna snake through here.
When we go up the stairs, we'll go to the right.
I believe probably we'll get attacked there.
And then we'll stay right.
Stay right.
I feel like the map kind of...
um shows you so much before you even before you even get there it's kind of spoilery did you just say snake through here you guys are worse than me maybe maybe
wait wasn't this the trailer I think I remember this part I remember this this This is so scary.
Oh, finally!
The pipe!
Give me a weapon, baby.
Use RB to light attack.
Though you won't deal much damage, you'll be able to attack more swiftly.
Use RT to heavy attack.
Your movements will be slower, but you'll deal far more damage and have a higher chance of stunning enemies.
Enemies take more damage while stunned.
X to lock on.
Okay.
The music is so good.
Holy cow.
Ouch!
Oh, she's...
Oh, I think she's done now, okay.
Oh.
Get Thanos?
Okay.
Thank you.
Um, hold on, Rinkle.
I'll come get you and like, Two seconds.
Yes.
Oh.
Take that.
Oh, I feel so much better now.
Having nothing is absolute...
It makes you feel the worstest ever.
We got stabbed.
Get the mistletoe.
Wrinkle.
Raincoat, my tommodachi.
Shu, Aibo.
Okay.
Trying to explore.
I'm a bit of a loot goblin, sorry.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I'm expressing.
Okay.
I might have wanted to...
Oh, counters!
Certain enemy attacks will leave them vulnerable to counter attacks.
A visual hint will appear when this is possible.
Use the visual hint.
Oh, when the visual hint is shown, use RT.
Visual hint indicating that counter is possible, but visible for longer when you're using LT to focus.
This one's a little hard, is it?
If no visual hint is shown during an enemy's attack, that attack cannot be countered.
Additionally, hints will not appear while Hinako is attacking or dodging.
So keep a close eye.
So like this.
We'll recover after some time.
Um, hello?
Hello?
Oh, I can't stay in focus for too long.
Ouch!
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
We're fine.
Ah!
Presti!
Oh my god, so much blood.
We're fine.
Wait, where did it leave me off at, I wonder?
Oh, come on!
Wait.
Now we are stronger this time.
Like, LT?
What?
Maybe not.
Okay, uh, ha!
Oh, oh, we got her!
Nice.
Okay.
Get the feeling Hinako might know some Kendo with that fighting stance.
You think so?
She said she was sporty.
We should be...
We can lock onto them.
What was it?
X, I think?
Not quite right.
This one, though, was tough.
I didn't see any...
Oh, there she comes.
I didn't see any opportunity at all.
The golden thing at the top of your health bar.
Wait, at the top of my health bar?
Oh, I thought it...
Wait, what's the green thing underneath?
Underneath them.
That's what I thought was my sanity.
Maybe I have to let her attack.
I was waiting!
She wasn't attacking!
Oh, that's stamina!
Oh my gosh, I keep thinking stamina and sanity are the same thing.
Wait.
Don't back up.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, hold on.
So I wait and then it's RT.
I'll try.
I'm not moving, but neither is she.
Ouch!
You bitch!
Oh my god, there it was.
Okay, I saw the...
I saw it.
Okay.
That one was not possible.
Oh, I pressed...
No, I pressed...
Oh, shoot.
I pressed B, I did.
Okay, alright.
Okay, whatever.
Oh, ah!
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait,
but I pressed it.
Huh.
I pressed RT!
Oh, oh, oh, RT!
Yeah, RT!
Oh my gosh.
The timing is so strict.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I did press it though.
Okay, mister.
Why is the music still going, though?
It's scaring me.
All right, we gotta go to the right side from here.
Wait, what's my health like?
I'm gonna...
Take another one.
Toolkit Restores Equipped weapons durability Uh oh There's durability Oh no Wait Use toolkits to repair weapons and restore their durability Short kits Short Oh my god Short kits Toolkits can be added to your item shortcut Using down Depod down Once a weapon's durability has been exhausted That weapon will break and disappear
No kidding No kidding
Am I dumb?
It's already added, no?
Unless it's... Wait.
How do I access...
Why is it in here?
How do I access this side of stuff?
Yeah, that is the scariest thing by far.
How do I know what my weapon's durability is at?
Oh, durability medium.
Okay.
Interesting.
LBD part.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Okay, hold on.
If I do that, and then I RB... Oh, okay, that switches it.
Got it.
Boy, I definitely expected to see...
Definitely expected to see someone down here.
Let's just run.
I was too scared to run.
Just kidding, I lied.
I ran for two seconds, and I regretted it.
Oh, yeah.
I mean,
up here?
Oh, wait, hold on.
Let me go check that one area.
Oh, yeah.
Here?
What is this area, actually?
Oh, I didn't check here.
We're being explorers.
Okay.
Oh, I definitely expected.
Did I see something here too?
Rominee!
Oh my gosh!
The best-selling soft drink in town.
It packs a fizzy, refreshing punch that wakes you up after one sip.
The Sprite of Japan.
Rominee.
Crazy replacement for the radio static, right?
Okay, let's go.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
We're almost there.
Okay, we just keep going down this area.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm scared.
Where?
Uh-uh.
Oh, gosh, I went right into her.
That's so bad.
Oh, I did the perfect dodge.
Yeah.
Die.
It's also, like, interesting timing.
Oh, gosh, my health.
Not so great.
Oh yeah, that's my favorite part of the song.
Ay yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo.
Ay yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo.
Pills here.
Nope, Ramanite.
Oh my gosh.
Pills here.
Nope.
Wait, is there anything in there?
Tease.
Such a tease.
Oh, it's saved!
Yippee!
Yay!
I thought it would stop once we got here, but clearly it didn't.
What other items do I have?
Oh.
Oh, this is an offering.
Wait, so there's no point in holding on to it.
If we can't consume it, I will offer it.
Clam!
Decreases enemy line of sight.
Interesting.
Okay.
Steel pipe!
Is that...
Oh, it shows the durability in the moon!
Oh, neat.
Okay.
Pills here.
I love alleyway pills.
I feel like I should be less afraid of monsters and more scared of Ikumi.
Him?
Okay.
I just got a notification on my computer and said, now available, Silent Hill F.
I'm playing it, I'm playing it.
Sakuko.
Oh my god, Sakuko!
No!
Our 500 yen!
Mm-hmm.
Did she bring her into the general store?
Now so much candy.
Wow.
Our friend.
Oh.
This day, I know.
Sakuko.
Finland is so nice.
Mm.
I don't even turn off the lights.
Don't run up their bill.
Are there bills in Silent Hill?
On behalf of Sakuko, please.
Thank you.
I want to see you.
Okay.
Uh, I learned my lesson?
Oh, shoot!
Oh.
Oh, my gosh, I can't dodge.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Ah!
Oh, my gosh.
Be careful, be careful.
Ouch, out, out, out, out.
Oh, I killed her.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, is this the time to just, uh...
Is this time to run?
I don't think I can.
Oh, damn.
I got them both.
Let's go.
I got one.
Shit.
Yeah!
Nice.
Nice!
Yeah!
She is studying the tomb!
Yeah, get his eyes.
Whoever the fog creature is.
Surrounded by fog.
Oh, the baby bird takes her first steps.
That's the achievement I got.
No.
We've been sent to... We've been sent to the void.
Hello?
I think I will.
I think I will nap a little bit.
Oh, wait.
Wow.
Where are we?
Find a way out.
Well, there's a door.
Wrong game.
This is not a way out.
girl fighting other cute girls.
No good.
I won't pledge.
Welcome, welcome!
Oh, Yashiro Sama.
Rika-chan!
Rika-chan, where?
What?
Okay, I'm not gonna lie.
See that little like ribbon on the on the jar?
I thought it was fried.
from far away thy restless heart betrays thee as unfit for this auspicious day thou must first pay respects to the gods and the spirits of thine ancestors a restless heart leads to a corrupt soul only through sufficient offering laid upon many stands may thy soul be cleansed now well thank you so much for the twenty gift and thank you
Altar.
Die rest.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Oh, so cute.
The pictures.
It might have started as a general store, but we've come to call it the candy store because half of what it sells is just snacks and toys.
So, where all my friends hang out.
My friends and I also meet up here.
Though we usually just sit outside and chat.
Ding fries are done what a monster of that appears to be lumps of flesh stitched together it approaches with an unsettling smile when it catches sight of me it's covered all over with sickening wounds I wonder if it wants to hurt me the same way that it was hurt so creepy sorry I haven't gone over some of these so far Nishida Rinko one of my friends she's really put together but can be a little inflexible in how she does things sometimes i think oh oh my gosh i was about to say i think she has a crush on shoe but then i saw the rest once she set her mind to something that's it and recently that something seems to be clothes fashion and other womenly pursuits rinko once confessed to me that she had a crush on shoe i told her that i was all for it but if she can't get used to the idea of rolling around in the dirt and catching insects for fun she might have a tough time how old is shoe like 10
Like, he looked at least like 15 and he's still rolling around in the dirt and catching bugs.
Huh?
What?
Why?
Is she a dog?
Oh my gosh, please stop spamming.
I'm not going to equip your thing because you keep spamming.
Thank you.
lucky lucky oh yeah added some more stuff to hers too oh unlike my sister Junko who was always the golden child I've been a handful ever since I was little my parents told me that I never listened to a single word they said I'd make my mom cry and my dad furious but Junko was always there for me she understood me she looked out for me that's why I loved my sister and have and have always done what she's asked of me or at least I tried She would smooth things out between me and my parents,
which made life in that house a little more bearable.
That is until she got married, of course.
What?
She's really not about this marriage.
She hates this guy.
Holy cow.
Okay, so we're placing things where they belong on the altar?
It seems?
You're supposed to stop doing that at some point, but bugs are cool.
It's the 60s, Minto.
Guys, just be collecting bugs.
Okay, you know what?
That's true.
What else are you supposed to do?
You need to equip my love into your heart.
Oh, la la la!
Um, okay.
Is there like a rhyme or reason, like this?
Oh, I can examine.
See, okay, see it has like the little bamboo.
I figured this was the bamboo one because it has like bamboo on it.
This has, it looks like an apple.
I can't tell the design on it.
Wait, oh, hold on.
Okay, the rat warning.
No, this has to be the leaves.
Because he's all bundled up in leaves.
Oh.
No.
Oh, it's a bird!
No!
Wait.
No.
Oh.
Let's try this one.
That...
A fish?
Oh wait, it kinda- well, I was gonna say all the animal ones are like on the outside.
I think I did it.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed!
How's the game so far?
Is it good?
Yeah!
Hello?
We are at home in the park.
Is this a boss?
Red means scary.
The sanity!
Oh, did I not make it?
Oh, I think I did.
Maybe?
Okay, here it is.
Open it!
Oh, did we get caught by Ikeman?
Oh!
Okay.
Wow.
Foxman.
Let's go.
Where do we go?
Where we go?
How do we go?
Hi, you know my name.
Who are you?
Yeah, what's this cosplay all about?
Oh?
Wait, can you, like, stay here?
Oh.
It's spooky in here.
I'm afraid of the dark.
Oh.
Oh, he's right there.
Oh, his eyes.
Wait, is he leading me to the...
Sanzu-no-kawa?
I don't know.
Are we getting...
Taken to the after...
I don't know who isn't all that bad at all.
I mean, it's got pretty girls, it's got pretty guys.
Okay.
There's a little bit for everybody, you know?
Wow, the visual is so cool.
Oh, there he goes.
Wait!
Wait a minute!
Silent Hill!
Silent Hill Japan!
Okay, I won't run then.
I like how his...
his lantern looks like a willow wisp.
Kyoto?
I don't know.
Your weakness, person with mask!
Don't say that!
Even if you're right, I wasn't gonna say it.
I thought it, but I wasn't gonna say it because I'm, you know...
Gosh, take it stop!
We were all thinking it!
Oh, it's raining.
Zootopia the Japanese word adaptation.
What do you mean?
You have one fox guy and suddenly you're in Zootopia.
And he, like, disappears, too.
It's cool.
I like this part.
Oh!
That's my friend!
Wow!
Oh, look at all the yokai!
Symbol of some kind.
Okay.
Look at that guy.
And that looks like a snake.
That's truly my favorite.
Wait, all of these have different things on them.
Look at that guy.
Okay, so these, okay.
Who did I not look at?
You?
What's your symbol?
Oh, and you.
Okay.
Oh, I'm not gonna remember these at all.
Wait, there's more!
Look!
Cat!
So cute!
Tidal!
Come.
Okay.
I'm not gonna remember these.
Oh, what's this one?
Okay.
Yeah.
Hmm.
The sound is so nice of them like, you can kind of hear them.
There's no wind.
Well, I guess there is.
They're like just barely moving and they're like clanking next to each other.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
I wanted to look at you!
Casa Obake.
My friends.
What else is there?
I think I've seen all of them now.
Interesting.
Is this a place to save?
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
These toes look kind of different.
Oh.
That's not what he said.
Why didn't they say that?
Like, why did they write her name?
Like, I guess maybe it follows the English dub.
That's okay.
Why is his lantern blue?
Because he is spooky!
Kaiken!
A beautiful dagger used for ceremonial purposes.
The blade has been intentionally doled so that it doesn't make the best weapon.
However, it does seem surprisingly durable.
The Inari statue is laughing?
Creepy.
Inari sushi.
Wait, what if I don't follow him?
Okay, just kidding.
You're right, you're right.
But like there's so many other pathways!
Don't give me the option if you don't let me!
I am an explorer!
Look at him over there.
He's fast, Harold.
go fast too.
I just like kind of taking in the atmosphere, you know.
Wait, where'd he go?
Inside?
What's a ginger?
Fox drawing.
Whoa, they're crazy.
Wait, that guy's got a bow!
What a good boy!
They're so cute!
Okay.
Oh.
Wait, why'd you take me over here, though?
Unnai shio.
Fox mask.
A mysterious man who wears a fox mask.
He never takes it off, so I feel I have yet to see his true self.
He has such a refined air about him.
I think he must come from a well-offed family.
For whatever reason, he seems to know me well and treats me kindly.
He's almost like a prince from a fairy tale.
In fact, this whole situation is like a story from a book.
Who are you and why are you leading me down this path?
Oh, oops, I did not mean to dodge.
Look how low my sanity is.
He's waiting for me.
Okay, I'm coming.
Where do you go?
You're so fast.
You've arrived?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Why is suddenly so scary?
This place has been so peaceful and nice!
Why?
Suddenly!
Oh, look at loops!
Oh, that's kind of nice.
Wait, uh, up here.
There we go.
Why you shut the door on me?
I didn't get- I didn't get to enter yet.
Rude?
Hmm.
Investigate the shrine vault.
Neat.
Wait, so is my sanity like...
Oh yeah, it's all back to normal.
Neat.
What's this?
Wait, why do you...
Look for any hints?
Ah.
Okay, so it's obviously the symbols that were on the thing, but how do we know which ones to do?
Maybe...
Hmm, okay, two of them.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go all the way back.
Why is it suddenly so scary?
We're not going to get, like, attacked in here, are we?
At least I know.
Game?
When do you think we'll see an answer to win this game?
Any second now.
Oh, you guys are doing smiley.
So I do get attacked!
Oh,
no, here it comes.
Oh, it's the doll from before.
Oh, oh, no.
Am I attacked by dolls?
Oh, no, no.
I'm not someone who's really afraid of dolls, though, are you?
I'm more afraid of the mannequin ladies.
I'm more afraid of mannequins than dolls.
Casting... wait, wait.
Lightning cast down from the heavens split asunder the decayed tree.
From the earth grows kudzu.
The prophet of eternal prosperity.
Kudzu sucks.
That stuff is... that stuff takes over.
Okay, this is... this is way worse than the dolls.
Oh, he's sick.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Is this a weapon?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm trapped.
Ah, trap, dodge!
There we go, nice.
Oh.
Oh, I have no stamina left.
Oh shit.
Oh my gosh.
Can I kill this guy or no?
Oh, shit.
I forgot to lock on him.
Thank you, guys.
Oh.
Okay.
Woo-hoo!
Oh, all right.
Yay!
I want you to counter.
Well, um...
Okay, so now...
We figure out the correct things.
What was it?
This one.
Oh.
It doesn't want me...
Okay.
Does it punish me if I accidentally choose the wrong thing?
Sure, hope not.
I'm trying to look at what the red symbol is, but it's way too small.
I don't remember.
if it spawns a new enemy, if you get it wrong.
It sounded almost like it would, right?
Oh, no.
What?
I don't think I understand the...
The... What's it called, though?
Like, the hint.
Check the journal button.
Oh, whoops.
Shrine Vault.
What was it?
Lightning cast up, down from the heavens split us under the decayed tree from the earth grows kudzu the prophet of eternal prosperity
would it be this one no are you kidding me right now
wait oh i forgot to see um i said it has it's surprisingly durable i guess there's no durability on it maybe there is it doesn't look like it can't tell where he is No!
He's just crawling over there!
Hold on.
Why are there so many spammers today?
Go away.
Oh
shoot.
What's he doing?
Okay.
I don't... I wouldn't like look at the things at my own leisure, please, sir!
Huh.
He's like doing some meditation or something.
Hmm.
He's emoting?
I don't know.
I think he's just going around in a circle.
At the moment.
Yeah, I think he's blind, so he's just like going in circles trying to find me.
Hold on, the music's so loud.
Um...
Yeah, he's just going around in circles, so we can at least look maybe.
But...
This seems like it might be...
Light... not the bird, this one.
I'm not sure.
Oh, whoops.
Wrong button.
I keep doing that instead of the journal.
Because my buttons are like switched, I think.
Lightning cast down from the heavens split asunder the decayed tree.
From the earth grows kudzu, the prophet of eternal prosperity.
What's kudzu?
It's like a vine plant.
it's like a plant it's like a vine that grows so much yeah lots of leaves yeah yeah yeah
it is very invasive they they bring in goats and stuff to eat the kudzu um because it spreads so much and it's so hard to get rid of it like and what it does is it spreads all across like a bunch of other plants and it deprives them of sunlight killing everything underneath so um so it's really bad to not it's not good to have
hmm is it native japan i'm not sure actually where it's from yeah i'm not sure daijin daijin anywhere wait is that the the guy with the lightning yeah There's the other guy, but...
One second.
Got a text.
I've seen it in Asia.
Oh wait, now I'm gonna look it up.
Where...
Is...
Hutsu from...
It's native to Japan, Southeast China, and...
Oh wait, this is AI.
It might be wrong.
Japan, Southeast China, and other parts of Eastern and Southeastern Asia.
Yeah, I...
watching videos of like them bringing in the goats to eat the kudzu are you in story mode i am i am this is my first time playing so they brought in kudzu in southern us thinking it would be great for cattle oh the cows don't like to eat it so now we have this plant that destroys everything
oh um well goats like to eat it the goats like to eat i love watching watch like a video of goats eating kudzu like a time lapse it's so satisfying it's like so fun to watch this is how i know about kudzu but apparently in japanese it's called kuzu kuzu i think
i'm dumb i don't understand the puzzle at all i mean i didn't expect it to be like in my face like this is lightning and this is plant You know?
What the heck was that?
Oh, there was like a weird sound.
It's pretty open if you look at it.
At all of it.
Is it?
I'm guessing the second one is this one, maybe.
This is not Kudzu, but...
It seems like a plant of...
Prosperity, no?
Eternal...
It's Prophet of Prosperity?
It's Ajisai though, maybe not.
Maybe it...
And the other one is Bamboo though.
Like that one.
This one here.
Oh, no, he noticed me!
No, he didn't...
I guess you did?
No, we didn't?
I'm looking.
I'm looking, because some of them have like very slight differences.
So I'm trying to see.
Oh my gosh, he's like right there.
He's just going in circles.
I don't like that sound.
what if this guy's the kudzu
wait lb examine oh okay that's what i okay this is the exam okay yeah i'm stupid i was thinking of lt or wait no oh it's lt or lb okay just kidding kudzu with legs wait what about this one this is all wait this might be the kudzu This might actually be the Katsu.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay.
Okay, it's a square with a T and a tail.
Okay, nice, we got it.
Square T-tail.
Okay, but the...
Eh?
Oh, there's...
Oh!
Oh, it draws it for me!
How nice!
Wait, there's three!
I only saw two on the thing.
Oh, I have to keep going?
Wait, there's other...
Oh my gosh, it's just like a needle in a haystack.
That's what they have you do.
Wait, I didn't see any other...
What's it called?
Did you guys?
Okay, once he goes around, we're gonna go past.
We're leaving?
Check the map.
Oh, good idea.
That over there?
The red circle?
I can't...
It said something about, like, finding your...
Finding the next objective.
I don't remember what it said, though.
Okay.
I don't know what that was.
Let that guy do his thing back there.
Over here.
You don't think you'll be able to hear me run, right?
Never hear me running, right?
Yeah, we're fine.
But what was this?
Something about preparing a key.
he locked the door on me it must have had something in his mouth that wait find the correct emma but i figured out that area or were there more i don't it didn't look like there were oh wait oh my gosh this map is so much bigger than i thought it was oh my god boy oh my god we haven't seen.
Oh no.
I was really enjoying this area.
Game, why'd you have to do this to me?
Why'd you have to make it so spooky?
I'm refunding the game.
My review?
Scary?
Zero out of 10 stars?
Okay, so there's a bridge here to...
Let's mark this down.
Okay, I think the map...
Remember how I kind of said it was, like, showing so much.
I think maybe it was just because it was the first level.
I was like, you know.
Yeah, I don't play Silent Hill to get scared.
What are you talking about?
Okay, so...
Our journal says, Lightning cast down from the heavens split asunder the decayed tree.
So maybe we find lightning and the decayed tree.
Hmm.
Wait, a tree?
In the middle?
Oh my god!
You guys are so right!
I completely missed that.
The VTuber is blind.
Okay, it was like a circle with the crescent.
And a line through it.
okay now okay i was right cool vtuber vtuber what would i do without you guys i would have just i would i would have just walked right by yeah it does kind of look like a basketball okay uh map okay the last one is right we just keep going
I should have done that first area first.
Or I mean, wait, first area last.
I don't know where he is.
Okay.
Lightning!
Ryden!
I am the Lightning Rebo- Oh!
Combination lock dial.
Okay.
We gotta get back.
Wait, what's this?
Blood-stained leather.
For those who have yet to abandon hope, I have hidden the Umamori that protects against evil behind the Emma at...
I can attest to its efficiency.
However, no power is absolute.
You must remain vigilant.
This heirloom belonged to my grandmother.
And now I pass it on to you.
I do not think of how much use for it now.
Behind what?
You are the lightning in that ring, Minto.
What?
Oh, my money.
I mean, where at?
Time to check all the Emma.
Oh, my gosh.
Watching Minto play video games gives me a nostalgic feel for when I used to watch my visual.
That was not very nice.
Did my game just save?
Is that what I just saw?
A save point?
Or no, I think it...
Oh, it was just telling me it opened the shrine vault.
Well...
I think it would be better to go back this way.
Less chances of running into the guy, I think.
The Emma stands out for a bit?
Oh like this one?
Greatly decreases the damage taken while dodging.
Look how cute that guy is!
I wish I could um Oh sorry Have more than one
We're taking it nice and slow and steady Baby We're not gonna go across Because he's right there
Yeah See that's why I didn't want to go the other area because that's where he all like...
He likes to hang out in this area.
I can't tell if there's more than one.
If there is...
Well, the other guy also likes to hang out in this area.
So we just...
We just steer clear.
A little bit.
Oh, what?
I don't think you saw me, did you?
Uh...
Alright, I'll just go across the bridge over there.
Is that Sheila's dog?
Oh, yeah, he doesn't have eyes.
You're right.
Well, I mean, do you think you heard me?
But maybe we're okay.
Am I going the right way?
Oh, my gosh.
I love...
I love that...
That skit.
Is that Sheila's doubt?
I think I've seen that from...
What was it?
Dropout.
My dropout Oshi is Zakoyama, so...
I like his skits.
Alright.
I don't think any...
Well, I'm not going to speak.
I will not speak.
I will not say what I think.
I do not think.
I am just getting...
I am just...
I'm just going inside.
Okay.
I was gonna say I don't think anybody spawned here Yeah Save the game I don't know how the saving in this game works quite yet Because I know it also auto saves But I don't know if me saving like that Like you know how I don't know Does it save my progress kind of dealio What was it The The button The basketball The T.
Basketball.
Oh.
T with the...
Wait, it is this, though, no?
Oh.
I thought it had a tail.
The auto saves are checkpoints where it continues and the saves are from when you want to quit, I think.
Oh, that makes sense.
Yeah, he left me!
Actually, he, um, like, really...
Uh, kind of, put me in a rough spot, mister.
With your beautiful eyes and your...
Beautiful fox face and your mysterious mask.
What are you doing?
Are you trying to kill me?
You hate me?
Yeah, bad Ikem.
What is this?
Stone key.
Ah, the key fashioned from a mysterious stone.
Judging from what he said, it's probably something precious.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
My brain.
It's gonna start shrinking.
He's such a red flag.
Is it the red mist that comes from seeing him?
Don't trust the fox, man.
Run,
time to run, time to run!
Oh my god, he's right behind me.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that scared me.
I didn't think he'd catch up to me.
Oh my god.
Ah!
I feel really welcome.
I'm not going to let it go.
I'm not going to.
Of course.
That's what I'm going to.
I'm still walking.
Yeah.
Oh no.
Oh, it's okay.
This.
If you're tired, then...
Okay.
Oh, she's fine, but I'm not.
Ma 'am, what about my feelings?
How about how I feel, huh?
Whoa.
What was she trying to do?
I don't quite understand.
Whoa, a styler, too.
Whoa.
I think we're going back home.
She was trying to close it.
Oh.
The fox's guidance.
The fox watches over the chicken coop.
Shoo!
Do you think he likes her?
Like, like, likes her?
Maybe.
Oh, la la.
Look at that girl.
She's just smiling.
What about Rinko?
Sakuko?
Oh.
Wait, what?
How did she get out of the general store?
Oh, that's her inside.
How did it get her so quickly, though?
I wonder.
He found you.
Because he found you.
...but there's only one.
No, no.
There's nothing else.
No, no, no, no.
But, it's good.
Because he found you.
...
Oh!
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
I feel like the music is so much louder compared to their talking.
I'm sorry.
She just went home?
Aibo.
So cute.
Mysterious Superchar.
Thank you!
Oh, sure?
Oh my gosh.
Why?
No!
Oh, he's still there.
Oh my god, you scared.
Oh, you scared me!
Don't leave!
This game looks more like Fatal Frame rather than Silent Hill.
Shoo!
Why did you leave me behind?
This guy!
Okay.
The doll.
Celluloid doll.
It looks like a doll that I had when I was young.
I don't have mine anymore.
But there was a time when it felt like a friend to me.
He put on his shoes and legged it.
Forget zombies.
Let's play Halo.
In my opinion, a doll is a toy for girls.
Because of this, I always felt like my doll was telling me I should act more like a girl when I was playing with it.
One day I was told by a girl that I couldn't play house with the other girls because I also hung out.
out with the boys from that day on i didn't want to play with the girls anymore and so i threw the doll away what what mean girls so mean dark shrine you a monster restrained by chains and shackles i wonder if it was imprisoned and tortured it seems to be searching for me by sound rather than sight i should be mindful of my footsteps you were leading the way at first but now the shoe other foot take notes fellas girls like masks keys and apparently ditching them constantly oh yeah oh we have more update on shoe i don't know what it is about shoes art but it looks like uh junji ito in a way
sakuko a little bit too it's like the eye i don't know something about it what do we got here shu is always had a vast knowledge of plants and flowers so his nickname came to be professor horticulture he has so many aspirations for his future he wants to be a gardener herbalist matsutake farmer and a member of the space army must be the line work yeah shu comes from a long line of pharmacists with his grandmother still working as one following the war a town doctor was finally able to open an actual practice.
Before that, the Iwais were said to have been stand-in doctors.
Ashu was a grandma's boy.
He spent a lot of time learning about various types of plants, flowers, and medicinal herbs that seemed to have sparked his interest in medicine, which eventually led to him learning first aid.
It seems he was interested in learning first aid because of his family lineage as pharmacists and to fulfill his duty as being a member of the Space Army.
Yeah, he has such high hopes.
Oh, I didn't know you could do that.
Oh, that's the, okay, that's the focus.
I just wanted to see the durability left of my weapon.
Okay, that was my bad.
I meant to press this instead of the focus.
And I was like, what's going on here?
We're focusing real hard.
Why did he leave me?
We could have been traveling together.
Where did he go?
He's like, I'm going to leave you if you don't hurry up.
Damn it.
When using focus with the LT, your sanity will slowly deplete while your gauge fills up.
Oh yeah, that's what just happened.
Your max sanity will decrease if you are attacked while using focus in action.
Oh, other than story.
Okay.
You abandoned Rinko too.
Yeah.
Once your focus gauge is full, use RB to perform a focus attack.
Your current max sanity will decrease, but you will unleash a devastating attack that varies with each weapon.
You can use items such as Domine and Divine Water or visit Hokura or choose Clear Mind.
What do you mean choose Clear Mind to restore your current max sanity?
If you have chosen story as your action difficulty level, then you can recover both your health and sanity without using faith by visiting Hokura.
I'm trying to focus on it or like...
Ew, it's so...
Oh my gosh, I love watching it move.
Oh my god, it's so creepy.
It's perfect.
Wow, bow, woo!
Inari no nakukoro ni.
She's gonna come back, right?
I want to do the focus attack.
Is that Shu?
Shu?
What's this one?
Oh my gosh, there's so much stuff all the time.
Oh, this is switching weapons, okay.
Well, this is just a tutorial, okay.
Where'd she go?
Is she gonna come back?
I hear her.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna RB!
Oh.
Oh, she's dead.
I got her.
That was RT!
Yeah, it was!
Oh,
that was silly.
Oh, those kinds of mistakes will actually kill you, huh?
Oh.
Whoa, look at all that.
That's craziness.
Wait, where am I?
We're going to...
Rinko's house, but where is it?
I want to zoom out, please.
that we cannot zoom out.
Oh, dominant.
That doesn't look good.
Let's go another way.
Let's just keep going towards where Shu went.
Yeah, we call that close enough quarters combat.
It worked.
No?
Wait, this area, it looks like it's all...
It's all messed up, but we can go.
It doesn't look so messed up.
Let's just keep going forward.
Oh.
I pray.
And I pray!
I pray every single day!
Is there anything we can give?
Yeah, but I can use these for sanity, so... and health.
I can't tell if this is crossing.
Yeah, okay.
Oh my gosh, Shu, where have you gone?
I'll take those for sure.
Thank you very much.
My health is... Okay, Max, awesome.
I can't really play too much today, guys, unfortunately.
decide when I want to next time though I want to play a lot a lot I'm wondering if I should maybe call it here I guess we're going in wait but this is not maybe we should go the other way because there's a lot of dead ends here like I don't know where her house is but I imagine maybe upwards would be better Let's go instead.
It's a good stopping point.
We did just get past that one thing, and we just saw...
I think right from here is probably a bit of exploration, so...
I think I'm gonna call it if that's okay with you guys.
That's all right with you guys.
Akira!
Thank you so much for the manganin!
I'll allow it.
Okay, thank you for allowing it.
Oh my gosh, this game is spooky.
But it also, it feels, I don't know how to describe.
Well, I guess it's been so long since I've played a Silent Hill, so.
No spoilers, but feel free to explore as much as you'd like.
The game will only ever prod you in the direction of the main objective.
But there's some other stuff you can find.
Oh, cool, okay.
Maybe we'll go down that other path then next time.
Kung Pao chicken, sweet and sour chicken, or Mongolian beef.
Oh, ghost of the YouTuber Charlie pick.
Thank you so much for the fine gifted!
Ducky, thank you so much for the gifted!
The next time I see you guys will be my birthday.
I'm gonna be gone for a couple days.
So, I will have a karaoke stream running.
There I go, thank you so much for the fine gifted!
But my birthday is next week.
And I have a three-day concert that I will be doing.
celebration the day after so really thank you so much for the ping and gato thank you so much for the ping thank you guys so much thank you thank you thank you wow so no well thank you oh my gosh thank you guys combo thank you thank you thank you me to gone forever no not forever uh that would be so bad um When is your birthday,
Mint?
It's October 1st!
So, just a couple, five days from now.
Just a couple days from now.
And, and, wow!
Ah!
I feel bad that, uh, my, my, uh, I will be gone until then.
So, I'm really sorry.
Okay, Barn, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
But I actually took this as, like, it was going to be a shorter trip.
And then I was like, then something else got planned.
to kind of for my birthday so it's a little bit of a birthday so birthday gift to myself it's an actual vacation for me
an actual birthday vacation i've actually i have no work the entire time so um but unfortunately it leads up to my birthday i apologize um safe travels thank you Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
So, yeah.
Enjoy your vacation.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
And finally, for pleasure, not business.
I know, I know.
Somehow, even my vacations end up becoming business somehow.
But I've got to get scanned for Mr. Kojima.
Don't forget to save.
I did save, no?
We saved.
Yeah, we're fine.
Camp patrol!
Thank you so much for the pink!
Thank you!
No, well, thank you for the pink!
Can't believe you're turning 19 again!
I know!
They grow up so fast!
Ah, Dorico, thank you for the pink!
Have your early birthday vacation!
Thank you guys, thank you.
So I will have the care- I actually am gonna put up the karaoke probably tonight.
A little bit after this maybe.
up i forgot to save no i didn't i just did i just did i'll save again happy board day thank you your one mission is have a fun and fulfilling vacation i will you're being gaslit me to save thank you forgot to save uh i think you forgot to have a nice day Look at me,
I'm being so nice.
Ah!
I'll miss you guys, though, even though it's just a couple of days, but it all leads up to...
The big concert, so exciting, exciting!
And of course, you know, I won't be gone, gone.
I'll be on Twitter.
And I'll be posting the countdowns as well.
And I posted today...
I posted today this one.
Every other day, I will show off a new person that will be...
Or people that will be...
in my 3D and so these are a special appearance by these four lovely ladies I got Doki, a yummy mama, Matara and Henya so yeah yeah yeah yeah and then on day four wait in four days left you will see another guest and then in two days left you will see another guest and then it will be the day yeah yeah yeah so um Exciting,
exciting, exciting.
I'm excited.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
Try for to thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Minto-chan, daisuki.
Thank you.
Easy toes.
It's an easy toes or easy TOS.
But thank you so much for the peg.
Thank you.
Second save in case it gets corrupted.
Make sure you save, by the way.
Oh, thank you.
I didn't realize.
I didn't save.
I saved my birthday quote for you next time.
right now my mind is blank no it's not my birthday yet so save it save it save it even you could you could send you could send on the on the fourth it's fourth sorry sorry the first or if you want it so that I can read it um you know because the 3d will be happening uh I will have the birthday party on the second so it's one day later but that's okay the fourth what's wrong forced to be with you.
Sorry, I got it in art now.
Oh, thank you!
I will go check it out.
Anyways, thank you guys so much for Silent Hill F.
This is so exciting.
This is so spooky.
It's so good.
Thank you for hanging out with me.
And I will see you guys when I see you.
Next time, next time, next time.
I want to play this game longer, for sure.
Sorry, it was such a short stream today.
Yeah.
Bye-bye.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye What's a meato?
What's a meato?
See you guys on my 3D Woohoo!
Bye bye